now you gotta say both cameras speeding
we're speeding
whoa you hear that we're speeding
[Music]
my name is george moats and i know a lot
about hamburgers
i know a lot about hamburgers though
that sounds obnoxious i'm not obnoxious
thank you thanks peanut gallery it is my
mission to preserve the american
hamburger in all of its forms especially
this one
ready for this one you've heard about it
before the double cheeseburger
are you thinking okay well so what
george i've had a double cheeseburger
but i'm gonna make a burger for you that
will blow your mind i'm going to make
the double cheeseburger
that birthed all other double
cheeseburgers this
is the original bob's big boy double
deck
hamburger arguably one of the most
important hamburgers in america
and guess what it has a very interesting
backstory with all kinds of twists
the double cheeseburger that we know
today was invented in 1938 by a guy
named bob wyan
at southern california's famous bob's
big boy restaurant
bob had a strong background in burgers
he worked his way up as a dishwasher
nearby in pasadena's right spot which is
credited of course with inventing the
cheeseburger
as the story goes one day some high
school orchestra members came into bob's
big boy and asked bob to make them
something
different bob went to work and created
an incredible feat of burger
architecture called the double deck
hamburger
which included two patties shredded
lettuce special sauce
cheese and even an extra bun this was a
massive leap forward for burgers which
at the time mostly consisted of just
beef and bread
even more fascinating the double deck
predates the invention of arguably the
most famous double cheeseburger in the
world
the big mac by almost 30 years
but getting there oh good stuff hello
before there was the invention of the
double cheeseburger by bob's big boy
if you ask for a double instead of
getting two patties you actually got
double meat
if you're traveling through america and
you ask for a double and they give you
two patties swished together on the flat
top you're in an old school place
but we're talking about the double
this is my homage to the original bob's
big boy
double deck hamburger let's go there
the uh construction of this thing is
very specific to what bob wyan did we
take a regular
seated bun see that we take another
seated bun
carefully just take off the top layer so
now we have basically
it's a round piece of bread i have three
pieces of buns see that look at that so
you have the crown
you have club and you have what's called
the heel the bottom of the bun
almost gonna get toasted let's do this
ready first i'm gonna start by smashing
southern california style salt
thick spatula you checking out my
spatula i saw that
well there's more where this came from
this would be something they would have
used a hundred years ago in america
maybe even earlier
one of my favorites this is the mason's
trial i bought in a hardware store in an
emergency on nantucket because we didn't
have a smash tool
that's what i picked up in japan look at
that beauty that's what i stole
got a fraternal order
in my opinion you could never have too
many spatulas
a lot of times if you go to a good old
southern california burger joint
they have pre-formed fresh pre-formed
patties that are super thin like
paper thin and the reason they're so
thin if you go to one of those places
so they cook faster it's as simple as
that they want to be able to get people
to hail out of that place with fresh
hamburgers
okay so next let's toast the buns very
important i butter both sides of the
club
goes on the flat top it's also getting
toasted over here
you're learning all kinds of stuff today
heel crown
club basically create a perfectly
toasted piece
of bread on both sides the club gets
turned over look at that yes
oh look at that see that that's pretty i
had to dope the bun
dope with the bun basically me it's
doping the bun there's another one right
there it's slogan slogan
doping smoking dough doping the bun
there's another one right there that's
slang for getting the bun ready for the
patties but you're coming right now
what a minute two minutes per side it
wasn't wasn't much at all
okay it does not get cheese right now by
the way no cheese goes on there you know
why
check this out mayo goes on the very
bottom a little bit of mayo on the top
of the club
a big handful of shredded
iceberg lettuce don't go fancy people
don't use leafy greens whatever that
[ __ ] is
on that we add a slice of cheese
unmelted that's right
unmelted american cheese on top of that
patty number one
is going on top of the cheese the club
then goes on top
of that now we have this middle piece of
bread between on top of the club goes
the second patty
right here and not a second slice of
cheese
only one slice of cheese on the double
duck hamburger okay on top of this
goes red relish i probably wonder what
the hell red relish is
i've really only seen red relish in a
few places there's a lot of places in
california
that use red relish it's really just
ketchup and
sweet pickle relish now you all notice
about me i don't put ketchup on burgers
ketchup can go [ __ ] itself as far as i'm
concerned but
if it's in a sauce it's okay i got to be
totally honest
it tastes amazing and on top of that the
crown
we crown this beauty and that's it look
at this thing
i'll be totally honest i have one of
these yesterday and i fell asleep
i passed the [ __ ] out just to give it
that one
last little kick of southern california
goodness i'm going to
wrap it in wax paper yeah yeah look at
that
oh my goodness now i'm going to try to
give it just the way they do it bob's
big boy they squeeze it
they go underneath they wrap it around
they fold it under
oh [ __ ] first try look at that
mine not yours
hmm that's insane
that is insane turning my griddle off
here
that's unbelievable that's truly
incredible
i mean this is this is america right
here that's it
i'm eating an homage to the first
double stack burger in america that's it
complete with a club in the middle i
could weep
but no i'm not going to weep i'm going
to eat
[Music]
oh goodbye it's not you you yes
[Music]
oh my god
wow nailed that one and you can too by
the way
you can do it you can do this give me
that back
i'll see you next time after i take a
[Music]
nap
you